[Music]
we knew they were going to try
everything to try to get donald trump
reelected
and the next step is sabotaging the post
office
and this is super important to know
about so
yes donald trump floated yesterday the
idea of delaying the presidential
election
unlikely to happen he doesn't actually
have the power to do it
he can mess up the post office pretty
badly and that's what he's trying next
so to set this up
coronavirus hits but we know we have an
election coming up in november okay
simple solution you vote by mail and
when we say vote by mail we don't mean
some new system we just mean expanding
absentee ballot access to anybody that
wants an absentee ballot
whether or not coronavirus is under
control in november
we don't know it's increasingly looking
like it's going to be out of control
but we expand absentee ballot access to
everybody we've got a solution for a
safe election
trump is against it trump is against it
because he says there will be fraud
trump doesn't understand that vote by
mail is the same
in this case as just absentee we're not
talking about a different system he's
either confused
or he's lying or he's distorting or
whatever we don't know
will governors mostly fortunately take
matters into their own hands and they
expand absentee ballots
they in some states say everybody can
get one
in others they say you still have to
have a valid reason for requesting an
absentee ballot
but fear of catching coronavirus counts
as a valid reason
some states are doing other types of
expansions but for the most part
governors do the right things so what is
trump's next move
well he's trying to neuter and kneecap
the post office donald trump has
appointed louis de joy to be postmaster
general
de joy just happens to be a huge trump
donor who
wants to see donald trump re-elected and
dejoy has announced
that he's going to eliminate overtime
for hundreds of thousands of postal
workers
over time widely expected to be needed
as we have a record number of people
opting to vote absentee rather than in
person
which could delay mail services and of
course prevent the
delivery of the ballots in other words
trump
through his postmaster general is trying
to cause the very problems
that he cited as the reason why we
shouldn't have vote by mail
louis de joy is also considering closing
a bunch of post offices
across the country and the joy is using
kind of coded language to try to hide
his intentions saying things like well
listen
we haven't done any kind of reform in
the post office for a long time we're
going to take a fresh
look at the operations of the postal
service this is all code now
we know that because of coronavirus and
because we know that absentee ballot
access
has been expanded in a bunch of states
around the country
there will be way more absentee ballots
this year than arguably in any prior
year
and we are just a few weeks from the
start of that remember four and a half
weeks from now
some states start voting absentee so
what do they want to do
cut the post office this is completely
obvious
three months before an election trump
puts in a big donor
to run the post office and immediately
trump's donor says whoa whoa stop the
clock let's reduce mail service
what people are emailing me saying how
is this legal that's a great question
this is extremely authoritarian
something we're now used to with donald
trump
this is another example of regulatory
capture
and this is another example of the right
wanting to suppress
turnout if you can't stop people from
going to the polls as easily
because lots of people are going to be
voting by mail prevent their ballots
from being delivered
by hurting the post office this is the
strategy
and it should be mentioned you know
sometimes i point out
democrats and republicans are both part
of
maintaining this status quo or they're
both
mostly on board with expanding the
military budget or whatever
this is not a both sides issue for is it
20 years is it longer
the right has had the strategy of trying
to hold down turnout
in certain areas to try to win elections
the left doesn't do this
the left doesn't consider as a top
strategy for winning elections let's
figure out how to prevent people from
voting
or how to prevent people's votes from
counting so first of all
number one we have to so overwhelm the
vote that these strategies won't work
i've been saying that for a year uh or
longer and
i hope that now everybody understands
why it's true secondly
there is a maybe possible backfire
effect here so
right now red states have been way more
hit by coronavirus than blue states
for now this could mean that red states
are doing more online shopping because
it's safer to go shopping in blue states
than red states
and so hurting the postal service might
actually
anger more republicans than democrats
now
whether they'll link it to trump's
postmaster and hold trump accountable is
another story remember that
when obamacare passed and republican
governors
opted not to do the medicaid expansion a
lot of those red state voters
blamed obama even though obama gave the
governors the tools it was the governors
who opted not to do it
they may not actually hold the right
people accountable but they are doing it
they're doing it right now this is not a
dress rehearsal
and that is almost going to be the
everybody must vote
and this is not a dress rehearsal or
very quickly becoming the phrases of the
next three months
dr anthony fauci the top infectious
disease doctor
in the country who has been trying to
run a coherent coronavirus response
and has been fighting against the white
house in order to do it
is now begging and pleading with
americans to just listen to science
understand and accept what's going on
and
it's like reasoning with little kids
unfortunately in much of this country
here he is on msnbc
again having to explain that we have a
process for studying whether a drug
works
and that hydroxychloroquine doesn't work
follow the science if a study that's a
good study
comes out and shows efficacy and safety
for hydroxychloroquine or any other drug
that we do
if you do it in the right way you accept
the scientific data
but right now today the cumulative
scientific data that has been
put together and done over a number of
different studies
has shown no efficacy so when there's a
video out there
for a bunch of people spouting something
that isn't true
the only recourse you have is to be very
very clear
in presenting the scientific data that
essentially contradicts that
we have such an education crisis in this
country we have such a media literacy
problem in this country
that the top infectious disease doctor
is having to spend
a non-negligible amount of time just
explaining to people
we know how to study whether a drug
works and this one doesn't work you
shouldn't be taking it
and meanwhile trump is insisting it's
good congressman kovid louis gomert
says he's taking it now that he has
coronavirus and this is how
dr fauci is having to spend his time
trump is still doing this
in the last 48 hours trump said the
following day
it's recommendations of many other
peoples and people
including doctors many doctors think it
is extremely successful
the hydroxychloroquine coupled with the
zinc and
perhaps the zithromycin but
many doctors think it's extremely good
and some people don't some people i
think it's become very political
i happen to believe in it i would take
it as you know i took it for a 14-day
period
and i'm here right i'm here
they seem to now see everything as a
matter of opinion it's all political
your opinion
is hydroxychloroquine works my opinion
is that it doesn't
these are just differing opinions the
obvious hypocrisy here
is that it's the right that has come out
waging this battle
against what they call post-modernism
from the left they claim you know the
left
thinks words don't mean anything anymore
everything's
just opinion there's no more real truth
and yet
they come out and then say well
our opinion is hydroxychloroquine works
when it comes to
what do the words man and woman mean the
right says the left
is playing too fast and loose with
definitions
and what things mean and yet here they
are
saying just a matter of opinion if
hydroxychloroquine works some people
believe it doesn't some people believe
it doesn't
as if science and medical studies don't
have anything to tell us about it
if their opinion is that a mask
could cause harm or as congressman covid
said a couple days ago
give you coronavirus then we have to say
well
their opinion is theirs and then we
might have scientific consensus but in
the end it's all just opinions
this is dangerous this is dangerous far
beyond the coronavirus situation that
we're dealing with right now
and this is also another problem i've
spoken of in the past
the idolizing of people over process
the idolizing of a cult of personality
when
it reigns supreme over understanding how
we come to know things and that's an
issue we've been talking about for years
in the united states we these are
estimates maybe 60
of the population will listen to science
because they understand how it works
the other 40 is a combination of people
who sort of listen to science even
though they don't really know how it
works but
it's sort of just like an argument from
authority for them and then an amalgam
of people who will follow
their religion or what they believe
their religion says or their
cult leader in this case the cult leader
can be a political figure
and this is unique to the right imagine
for a moment
joe biden were president coronavirus
hits and joe biden comes out and says
you know doctors say hydroxychloroquine
doesn't work but i think it does you
should take it
you're not going to see a lot of
leftists go and say joe biden said
hydroxy works
i'm going to take it even though doctors
say no this is a phenomena of the
american
right it does not exist in the left to
any kind of significant degree and this
is a cult-like
aspect of the right in the united states
and it's not just the type of thing we
talk about in
in academic settings this is causing
very
real and concrete problems and if you
think it's bad now with this
hydroxychloroquine stuff and the mask
fiasco
just wait until a vaccine comes out
which maybe is
60 70 percent effective but 40 percent
of the country
may refuse the coronavirus vaccine
as some studies expect will happen
40 45 of the country may
opt not to get a coronavirus vaccine
once it is available horrifying
absolutely horrifying make sure you're
following me on twitter at dpakman
and remember you can get the daily audio
podcast every day you don't have to
watch the short youtube clips if you
prefer a long form
audio format when you're working out
when you're doing
whatever it is that you're doing
gardening your zooks and cukes maybe
like me
grab the audio podcast on itunes
stitcher spotify pandora
whatever your favorite podcasting app is
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are colin
mcginn
and darren white thanks to colin and
darren for your support
also today's long time sustaining member
of the day
is frankie perdue frankie's been a
member almost five years
really appreciate your support frankie
join these great people
this is my please clap moment please
join at joinpakman.com if you
like the normal prices for membership by
all means sign
up if you don't like them take advantage
of the coupon code
this is 2020 which will save you 40
percent
off of the cost of a membership let's go
to the phone lines the phone lines are
hopping today see what's on folks
minds the number is of course
617-830-4750
let's start with our caller from the 828
area code
caller from 828. what's your name where
you're calling from
hello uh this is patrick i'm calling
from near asheville
north carolina what can i do for you
patrick
i had a sort of proposal for you to
[Music]
uh encourage accelerationists or
revolutionary leftists to vote for joe
biden okay
i would propose that joe biden is
actually
their acceleration as candidate of the
two candidates that are available or or
joe biden is actually an accelerationist
candidate
of the two that are available okay
because
um if you're familiar with the the j
curve theory of revolution that
revolutions happen when expectations
don't meet reality
so if trump gets elected everyone will
expect things to get worse
and become more authoritarian yes joe
biden gets elected people will expect
things to get better but i would say
they won't get that much better and that
might be more likely to cause a
revolution than if trump gets elected
that's very interesting so to say it
another way patrick
the idea is if trump wins
and people expect the world to get worse
and it does um expectations and reality
will be aligned
and often that will not cause dramatic
change
on the other hand if people vote for joe
biden
and other other than the
accelerationists i guess a lot of people
believe things will get better if joe
biden is elected they might not be great
but they'd be better if it then doesn't
happen
it might actually catalyze a demand for
more significant change
is the idea yeah that's right
it's interesting i mean i don't know
listen i don't know that i believe it
so what you're basically saying is would
this be a way
to convince the sort of never biden
people to vote for biden the
revolutionary left to vote for biden
but it's something i don't actually
believe will happen i don't know if it's
honest to use trickery but it's
certainly an interesting idea
it's more of a possibility i mean if
you're looking at odds
odds are better for joe biden in that
either he makes things a lot better and
that's good things get a lot better
or they only get a tiny bit better which
could also be good if you're an
accelerationist and that
change will happen more likely it's an
interesting idea i mean i'll propose it
if i get one of these revolutionary
leftists calling in i'll certainly
propose it to them and see what they say
okay thank you and i had one other quick
question sure
um when you're speaking in spanish would
you pronounce your name
david or david well in spanish
it's david yeah um
i would just say when aoc becomes
president you might need to
explain what code
sorry i might need to you you're
breaking up patrick i might need to
explain what when aoc is president
code switching code switching okay well
yeah
that's uh that's something to think
about
uh patrick thank you for the call very
much appreciate it
uh let's go next to our caller
from the 661 area code who's calling
today from 661
hey david a long time viewer here from
lancaster california and i just had a
quick question for you
sure the
rhetoric that trump and his campaign has
put forth
since his uh election since he started
running in 2015
i feel as though it's directly led to a
rise in deaths of despair in america
alcohol you know liver disease
suicide drug overdose
and also just overall violent crimes
hate crimes things like that and i
actually
wanted to know if you had any thoughts
on that any
well no i have no particular thought i
mean so there's a couple different sides
to that
so deaths of despair often are related
to economic circumstances
and um certainly it would be a
counterpoint to the idea that before
coronavirus
things were better than ever because if
things were better than ever you would
not expect
many of these deaths of despair to be on
the increase now in terms of the hate
crimes and crimes targeting
religious minorities or ethnic
minorities or whatever the case may be
i i've said before i don't think trump
has
created racists or xenophobes and
whether trump is personally racist or
xenophobic is less relevant what matters
is
trump has made existing racists and
xenophobes
more comfortable to be out in public
with their views and has emboldened them
and so it's also not particularly
surprising but i think the deaths of
despair are sort of
a different phenomena than uh that than
some of these
hate crimes and other violence
okay i appreciate the answer and uh
all right thank you yes that was the the
audio quality there was brutal i
apologize for that
um let's go today to our caller from the
250 area code who's calling today from
two five zero
hey david my name is ashlyn i'm calling
from um
i'm actually calling from canada i'm not
from victoria i'm not sure
you know where that is it's just a
couple hours north of seattle
okay a couple hours north of seattle
what's going on today
um i should have a quick question for
you i don't know how quick it is
actually
but um so i think that you're probably
aware too that like
the the eviction crisis is going over
pretty soon here probably in the next
couple months if not the next month yes
and i was wondering what you think
of uh strategically withholding
rent as a tactic and how do you think
that would pan out
in the us or how how effective do you
think that would be
so i've actually i'm glad you're asking
this i've talked about you know i've
done a bunch of segments and there's one
in particular about
types of activism where i've said you
know calling your representatives is
great
um signing petitions online i don't
think it really does anything
but the activism tactics that may get
more attention would be
mass rallies in urban centers strategic
defaults
of debt of different kinds which could
include coordinated non-payment of
mortgages
coordinated non-payment of rent etc
um i i think the complexity right now
is it wouldn't just be activism like
there's 32 percent of people were unable
to pay their entire mortgage
or rent on july 1st so what we're
talking about is
an actual economic crisis in which a
third of the country wasn't able to
fully make their july 1st payments
and then adding on top of that another
element of this happening
strategically during a time when there
may be an extended
eviction moratorium or there may not
it's
unclear they're talking about it but
it's not clear a deal is actually going
to get done
so it's extremely speculative what would
happen in this particular case
the idea for people to understand of
saying
nobody pay your mortgages nobody pay
your rent is that if everybody
really did it and of course everybody
would never do it there's a huge part of
society that would say
i'm fine i'm not going to get involved
in this i'm not going to hurt my credit
or whatever
but if a large enough portion of society
withheld mortgage and rent payments
you would instantly [ __ ] the
financial industry with a massive
liquidity crisis
it would probably force the government
to have to in the short term
put in a crazy amount of money to keep
these financial institutions afloat and
the
idea would be it would bring
stakeholders to the table to actually
negotiate some of the change that
people people want now agreeing on what
the change people want
is is a whole other issue and brings
complexity but it's an interesting idea
i don't know what
adding a strategic default on top of an
existing
eviction and foreclosure crisis would
would really do a potential one
uh but it's a it's a very interesting
question
yeah i think like uh quickly like i
think it would
it would pan out a lot worse in canada
where there is a little bit more
of a social net for people uh but i
think in america i think where i don't
know
if the social network is quite there so
this kind of
i think the the the view on it would be
a little more positive
in certain places versus other places
right so that's why i was asking you how
you thought it would
pan out in the u.s but yeah i i really
appreciate your song i mean listen
if it happened if you had a
significantly coordinated
mortgage and rent default in the united
states
it would immediately become
hyper-politicized where
it would be you know attacked by the
right
as just grifter lazy people on the left
who don't want to pay their bills and so
on and so forth the left would likely
hail them as
uh doing something really good in order
to inspire change potentially at their
own
economic peril and it would become
honestly just like everything else where
it would become hyper partisan
and i don't know how far we would get
with it unfortunately
yeah fair enough i agree with you there
yeah all right my friend thank you for
the call very interesting question i
appreciate it
let's go next to our caller
from the 616 area code who's calling
today from 616.
um hey david am i on yes you are who's
this
um my name um my name is
it's john paul jones i'm from western
michigan and
i just i just wanted to bring up a
little a
bit of an interesting point i've been
thinking about
now hold on did you say your name is
john paul jones like the great bassist
the great fool uh isn't led zeppelin's
bassist john paul jones
um nothing no i i'm not sure
the person i'm most familiar about with
that name is john paul tells the famous
historical sailor
i got it okay very good all right we'll
go on
um i was just
um see i see about well
since about three months ago jeffy
ventura announced that he was considered
running for
the green party presidential nominee
by but eventually this was some sort of
heat a potential health problem he was
forced to
drop out but here's the thing i actually
think the situation right now
alex i was so bad where we could use a
green party cat they might actually
stand a chance
this year and i i'm thinking that if the
green
if holly hawkins surrenders to the green
party nominee to jesse ventura so i mean
his health problem is gonna
flip away wait hey the green party may
actually have a chance to
win in some states or or if things get
so bad maybe even
even even the presidency um
no so john paul jones let me let me so
there is absolutely no chance that a
green party candidate wins a single
state it it there's no chance of that
whatsoever
um joe biden is polling over 50 percent
uh in a huge number of states and
nationally and really the only thing a
green party candidate might do
would be hand a state where it's close
to donald trump so a green party
candidate would not win a single state
and they
certainly would not win the presidency
at this point
oh um yeah okay i was just
okay um um okay i was just
well i would just think think about
thinking about that because yeah because
i
think they're just so well i saw nothing
in the u.s like
right now that that when things get bad
people
can usually get desperate and and
well you know yes
you're thinking about all the right
things things are bad but uh
no the green party in this election
could only potentially
uh be a major major spoiler so let's
let's let's let's get trump out of there
let's get joe biden and that's the next
step all right thank you my friend i
appreciate the call
we're gonna go to a very brief break
it's gonna feel so short
but then we'll be back with more phone
calls so please don't hang up if you are
on hold because we are going
directly back to the phones
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's get back to the phones at
617-830-4750
i want to talk to our caller
from the 202 area code who's calling
today from 202.
hi david this is rachel from the uh
maryland
suburbs of d.c love it and and rachel
you don't have us on speakerphone do you
i do not you're on a headset are you
unable to hear me
you know it's okay i think we can deal
with it
okay so my question to you is around
like the corporate liability shields
um it seems like that's mcconnell's like
red line
uh and he doesn't care about
anything else my question to you
is do you think this is something the
democrats might cave from
okay von i mean they've kind of some
have kind of postured around
um not you know that being a non-starter
but i mean basically the language that
was submitted
came from you know cuomo's liability
shield that he
you know uh put in in new york to use in
new york
so rachel let me explain to people first
what you're talking about so people know
so
the idea here is donald trump floated
this starting a couple of months ago the
idea is
a liability shield for businesses who
reopen
where they would not be subject to a
lawsuit
or or criminal or civil proceedings of
any kind
if people catch coronavirus at their
place of business it could be employees
and it could be customers the idea being
if a business
thinks wait a second if my employees get
sick or customers get sick i could get
sued
they'd be less likely to open so donald
trump's side as a way to
really encourage businesses to open
you know i i i would have my answer
two weeks ago rachel might have been
more definitive at this point i think
everything is on the table
i think uh given what's going on and
given how far apart the negotiations
seem to be
democrats more than republicans seem
extremely eager to get
money to people and get money in
people's hands that they might be
willing to concede
i i would not it's a question mark for
me i wouldn't put anything past anyone
at this point particularly when
you've got an election in three months
and so a lot of the players who are up
for re-election in the senate
are going to be thinking about what
they're willing to do versus what
they're willing to give up
in order to facilitate getting
re-elected as well
so it's a crapshoot right now anything
could happen
yeah i mean i'm i'm just very concerned
that it could lead to
a potential fight because once you have
people who are absolved of liability
then their interest in trying to do
everything they can
to maintain worker and consumer safety
becomes a little less i mean we saw what
happened in the nursing homes in new
york
so i'm just that that's really what you
know it's concerning to me is that could
it lead to a further spike
well listen the answer is yes and of
course
we may be on the way to a further uh
spike anyway
and we were supposed to have a break
between wave one and two
it's not clear that's going to happen so
yeah all these factors are going to add
it's it's looking like it's going to be
a very difficult fall in the united
states
absolutely great well thanks david
thanks rachel appreciate the phone call
let's go next to our caller from the 206
area code who's calling today from 206
david i can hear me yes i can who's this
pleasure to finally meet you i'm logan
rogers
originally from florida but currently
living in seattle i love it
got kind of a setup for you thank you
i've got kind of a setup for you with a
little bit of just i want your opinion
on something that's been personally
going on politically in my life
but uh very recently i had a couple
friends of mine that i moved out from
florida to move into my house in seattle
and i've known the man for a good like
four or five years
and he has a girlfriend and we recently
had a little bit of a
you know quarrel over this whole black
lives matter protest
you and the girlfriend had a coral yeah
yeah she's she's more of a
she's from ohio and uh he's from
florida and he's got you know
progressive politics they both do
but she just couldn't get over the fact
that property damage was being
occurred because of these protests and
that she like
basically didn't really approve of it
and i made the point to her
because she was one of the people being
like you know not all cops are bad
people
there's there's a lot of good cops and i
tried making the point to her that
if you have 3 000 good cops that do good
things and for bad cops that do really
really bad things and those 2 000 cops
don't say anything about that
you still have 2004 bad cops and she
took it extremely personally because she
has
a lot of police in the family and
basically thought that i said that her
dad was a racist that kills black people
okay and they haven't talked to me in
about three months
now and they moved out and it's really
really been kind of hard on me because i
love them both
and my my political verbal skills aren't
nearly as refined as yours i must say
and i was just wondering like where
where would you take that relationship
you're saying at the point at where it
is now what would you do
yeah i mean it really depends on what
your what your goal is
is the goal to uh sort of uh
fix the damage that has been done
pretty much yeah i'd like to really do
that well i mean i don't know these
people it's very hard for me to say but
i would try reaching out and saying
i feel terribly about the
outcome of our relationship you don't
necessarily have to say i take back what
i said because it sounds like you don't
and in that case you shouldn't i
wouldn't lie and say you were wrong in
what you said if you believe you were
right in what you said
but you could say i really regret how
this went and would you be open
uh to talking to me i mean i don't know
that there's really that much more
that there's that much more that you can
do you can just say forget it you can
say i'm gonna wait for them to reach out
if they ever
do or you can be proactive but i don't
know that i have any special insight
based on the subject matter
okay all righty well you know i'm just
trying to reach out and just find people
to you know you seem like a very
reasonable person to talk to about these
things so thank you for taking my call
um just quick little shout out i really
really appreciate you guys you and kyle
uh
i'm from florida originally i come from
a very conservative background
and i was pretty racist for a long time
really thank you guys for everything you
guys do oh yeah
i was like purebred like you know get
these mexicans out the border kind of
thing
so what like yeah now get these mexicans
out
what what beliefs did you have about
mexican people
uh well you know again i was raised in
the southern conservative family so
just basically all the normal racist
tropes
that you would hear you know like uh
they're taking their jobs
they're you know dirty you know
infested people who are just you know
coming over here to like you know
make america not white you know like i
was i was pretty bad man
i'm not gonna lie like i've come a
little i've come a long way
that's that's incredible and so now when
someone
when you run into someone that still
believes that are you better positioned
to disabuse them of those beliefs
or or not really i've de-programmed
probably two people
really that i know of that are my really
good friends oh yeah yeah
my friend in idaho was a really big ben
shapiro guy
and uh ironically making showing him
you and kyle actually brought him around
being like
these guys are much more reasonable
sounding yeah 100 was there any
particular issue where they started to
be open to other ideas like was it on
you know immigration or social issues
economics where they said oh maybe
this other set of ideas actually is
making more sense to me
specifically for just my one friend i
think it was healthcare more than
anything
interesting okay yeah
and how recent was that was that during
coronavirus or prior to
three it was pre-chronicles about
december last year that's interesting
that's interesting
thank you well congratulations i mean
you've programmed yourself and two
people that's already more than most
people can say
so i hope that the relationship is
rekindled if that's the way you want it
to go and i really appreciate the phone
call
thank you so much david all right take
care tough situation there
that's a tough situation let's go to the
next caller
from the 303 area code who's calling
today from 303
david can you hear me yes i can who's
this
hi so i just go by t um i'm originally
from colorado currently living in
massachusetts on the north shore how are
you doing
i'm doing well and you said like the
letter t is the name you go by
yes how did you get that name i'm
curious
oh just a shortening of my name to be
honest i'm trying to
uh anonymize my political opinion um
uh because i find that i've actually
suffered some
uh uh career setbacks by virtue of
sharing
um my politics online really
are your politics left or right
um i'd say uh progressive left uh
libertarian
and and and in what industry or field
can you say generally have you been
um hurt due to those beliefs
uh so i've been in uh software in uh
product management in software being
progressive
hurt you that's interesting that's not i
wouldn't necessarily assume that
uh well you know it's part of the sort
of corporate infrastructure of the world
yeah i gotcha okay well what's on your
mind today
so um yeah so i guess by way of sort of
quick exposition to my main question
um have you heard of the concept of
federal decentralization
federal decentralization i mean maybe
maybe but not by that name what
what specifically do you mean by it yeah
so fair enough so
there are several types of federal
government or government centralization
but the sort that most
interests me is a political and regional
one
which in practice would mean basically
reducing federal government over
authority over policy making and
delegating it to a
smaller number of regional subsets of
the federation that are more aligned in
terms of
like politics and culture and history
sure um so so i've basically i've been
working on this project and i've
identified five
such regions and the closest analogy uh
those
probably by no means perfect would be
the coven 19 regional coordination packs
among states um which hasn't really come
up
much lately but uh i'd apply that to
sort of the political system as a whole
so what would the regions be you've got
you've got new england plus new york new
jersey right that would be one region
sort of the northeast
so uh yeah so essentially it would be
like the the boston washington
uh corridor and probably extending a
little further to
uh northern north carolina which is by
far the most uh the most uh
uh like liberal um for lack of better
terminology
um you know part of north carolina um
the second would be uh the the west
coast
uh but including some inland territory
the um front range
uh of the rocky mountains and through
uh northern new mexico um
and southern uh arizona would be the
second one
um the third would be basically the
center of the country
essentially um the fourth would be
essentially what we call
kind of most the midwest um but
including upstate new york
uh vermont and uh northern new hampshire
and
maine and the fifth would be uh the
fifth would be the um
basically the southeast uh but it's
basically been
um sort of lacking for
representation um in federal government
due to state boundaries
okay i mean i guess i could take issue
with a couple things there number one
that west coast region is including some
pretty dramatically different areas
you've got the ultra liberal parts of
the country
and also extremely rural conservative
parts the way you've done it i also
would
you know the idea of also dividing
states where part of vermont is in one
region part of vermont
is in another maybe it's a little
complicated but okay i understand
i understand the framework so now i
think we can get to the question piece
yeah so really i was mostly just
interested in you know when this time
that we live in where we're
sort of have very different approaches
um it's a very polarized world
uh very polarized country i should say
um where we have these very different
approaches to covert 19 to the racial
justice
protests and sort of the proper response
to them
i'm just curious if you think this this
model as a whole
whether or not we agree on boundaries
you know is an open question but
sort of the approach as a whole um i'm
just interested to hear kind of your
perspective
well listen i i'm not like a secession
type guy where i think the country
should necessarily be
split i think that the level of chaos
that that would cause and
bring up a whole new bunch of
immigration issues so i'm not like a big
divide up the country into different
countries
type of guy however particularly during
coronavirus
yeah i mean listen new england plus new
york and new jersey
are running coronavirus responds one way
what's happening in the southeast is
completely different i mean it has
nothing to do with it
whatsoever and the us is so big that you
know really these regions are like
european countries in many ways
sometimes geographically
sometimes in terms of population so i do
think that
there are significant enough cultural
differences
differences in business you know the
primary businesses of different
areas that it may it intuitively makes
sense that we should be thinking of the
us
more regionally now the thing is we
already have 50 states so you could say
we already do that
states rights 50 states 50 each state
can do what's right
for them but that doesn't what i think
that ignores
is that there are certainly groups of
states that are very similar in a lot of
ways the states with
you know the best health and education
systems often are close together
so so i like this idea of thinking about
some problems more regionally without
saying we've got to secede or divide up
the country
i think the devil is in the details but
i'm very open to that
that's awesome to hear yeah no i think
uh just just one point of clarification
so i'm actually not in favor of you know
secession
oh yeah yeah no i wasn't saying you i
was saying it more so people don't think
i'm saying split the country up in this
way yeah
yeah i mean that that's kind of why i
formulated under this federal
decentralization model but um if i might
uh just plug
quickly so um i've started a project on
twitter called the decent
fed project um at decent fed proj
um if you or any of your listeners want
to check it out
um it's just you know it's it like i say
i come from a software background so i'm
kind of a systems
guy so i'm interested in kind of new
approaches to governance that might
you know improve the situation in this
country and um
you know in all honesty look like with
how polarized we are
you know maybe diffuse some of that by
saying you know this part of the country
is more
progressive on economic and civil issues
and this and civil liberties issues and
this part of the country's more
um conservative you know maybe a way to
do to to
resolve that um discrepancy is allow
them to kind of
go their own way a little bit in terms
of their um
policy making yeah and as we've seen
with coronavirus there's nothing to stop
a group of states from saying we're
going to work together and just
basically have the same policies
on on this set of issues or that sort of
issue so i think legally it's also far
cleaner than some of the other things
that are proposed
all right t from the north shore i
appreciate the phone call
um that is going to do it for live calls
today
let's go to a break and we'll be back
right after this with more friday show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
davidpakman.com
gear don't miss the bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com
forward slash gear
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let's get right into audience questions
today first one
is about these so-called secret trump
voters hey david i keep
hearing about shy or secret trump voters
sometimes called the silent majority
is this really a thing do the polls not
understand
or account for trump voters who simply
aren't willing to say
they are going to vote for trump so
listen in broad strokes the answer is
that the secret trump voters don't
really exist
there are people who point to 2016 and
they say look the polls were so
wrong people clearly weren't telling
pollsters that they were planning to
vote for donald trump
because they felt some kind of public
shame or they were embarrassed or
whatever the case may be
the polls were basically right in 2016.
hillary was winning by three in the
popular vote she won by 2.2
um these states like i believe that
there was one state that really was
wrong but for the most part the
battleground states that were close
the margins of error were accounting for
the actual results
so 2016 doesn't really give us evidence
that there were secret trump voters the
idea being they hide their preference
from pollsters
until they actually go out and vote
a big difference between 2016 and 2020
is that i don't know
why someone would be particularly
unwilling to
admit today that they plan to vote for
trump in a poll
remember this your family you know your
friends
nobody's going to find out how you voted
in a poll a lot of the polls now
are completely automated so it's not
even that you might be embarrassed
to tell the pollster that you're
planning on voting for trump there
really would be no reason
why if i get a poll and says this is you
know ssrs
press one if you plan to vote for biden
plus press two if you plan to vote for
trump
why would i be shy about just answering
truthfully there
the only argument that could be made
would be trumpists have
coordinated to claim they are voting for
biden
in order to give biden a lead in the
polls
which will motivate more trump voters to
get out and vote in november
it's a complete argument you know it's a
post hoc
argument made to justify something we
don't actually have evidence for
and it makes no sense to me whatsoever
there were no you know there's no
evidence that there were there are more
shy trump voters than there were shy
obama voters or shy hillary clinton
voters or whatever
certainly there is a significant
cultural divide in this country where
there could be social stigma at work
from being one of the few trump voters
if you work at some tech firm in austin
texas a state that's likely to go to
trump but austin is much more blue
maybe you might not tell your co-workers
that you're going to vote for donald
trump but why would you lie in a poll
your co-workers would never know that so
my sense is it's not so much that what
could turn the election would be
that trump has way more support than the
polls say because of secret trump voters
what's more likely to me is that there
is a part of the base
that doesn't get involved until election
time and
maybe they are more prevalent on the
republican side than the democratic side
maybe joe biden's support is fully
represented in the polls
but some trump support is still sitting
out there as
on i don't know or third party
or whatever because people aren't
necessarily paying attention yet or
whatever the case may be
i'm still manning the argument i suspect
that
that would be a small portion of the
electorate
and i don't imagine that you are going
to see any significant
amount of shy trump supporters
or reticent or maybe embarrassed trump
supporters who are going to vote for
trump in november
but for one reason or another are lying
to pollsters today
last thought the other argument is
it's not that there are shy trump
supporters
it's that trump supporters are
skepticals of polls skeptical of polls
so they opt
out well the polls are normalized and
adjusted to make sure that the samples
are representative if you were
imagine that you had trouble getting
trump supporters
to respond because they hate pollsters
and so you would think oh well you're
under
representing trump supporters trump
supporters in the poll no you just
adjust
and normalize the sample to account for
that and pollsters have a number of
different methods that are
scientifically uh statistically
acceptable in that case
if we're wrong then we will know very
very soon
hey david do you think that donald
trump's new tone around coronavirus
taking it more seriously
and wearing or carrying around the mask
is going to help him turn the election
around
i i don't think so no i mean i think
it's too little too late you know
for the first four or five months of
coronavirus in the united states
trump continued to say everything's fine
refuse to wear a mask
masks are you know it's your choice you
can wear it or not wear it or whatever
we have 15 cases it'll soon go to zero
etc etc etc in the last 10 to 14 days
we saw trump with a mask out in public
he keeps it in his suit pocket
uh during his coronavirus press
briefings to be able to pull it out like
a prop at any time
he has actually said some things that
are more sober like it could get worse
before it gets better and on and on and
on
will this turn around the election for
donald trump i don't believe so
um i don't believe so because number one
the cat is sort of out of the bag from
the standpoint of coronavirus
even if indeed the trump administration
is now covering up
cases since the changeover from
reporting data
to the cdc instead reporting data to
health and human services we covered
that earlier this week
people know that they're unemployed
people know that their friends are
unemployed people know the economy is a
catastrophe people
disapprove of trump's handling of racial
issues which is the third most important
issue going into november so i think
trump putting a mask on now
and saying this is tough is simply not
going to be
enough now could it still be important
as far as keeping people safe in other
words will trump supporters
start wearing masks because trump has
worn a mask
i seriously hope so because that is one
of the most important things that we can
do we covered on a bonus show earlier
this week
there's a lot of hygiene theater you
know restaurants announcing we're going
to close an hour early
to spray with some disinfectant
the entire restaurant or whatever
there's really no evidence that
significant contagion is happening
through surfaces in that way
you know cleaning tables and seating
surfaces between
guests uh should be more than enough so
there's like hygiene
theater stuff that does not really seem
to hold down contagion
wearing a mask does wearing a mask when
you're indoors
avoiding crowds that's the stuff that
really matters and so if trump carrying
his mask around
helps more trump supporters feel okay
putting on a mask
then that's great and i would be crazy
to oppose that and i don't oppose it
now there's one other component to this
it is possible that trump wearing a mask
and then more people wearing masks as a
result
will increase the number of people that
feel comfortable going and voting in
person in november maybe there were
people in november
who maybe were going to stay home but
now we're going to go out now
i'm thinking of democrats what i mean is
the following
if you're a trump supporter and you're
already not paying attention to masks
you're going to go out and vote in
person in november if you're a democrat
and you care about masks and they aren't
mandatory or a lot of people aren't
wearing them
you might stay home because others don't
plan to wear a mask
you seeing more republicans wearing
masks
might make you as a democrat more
comfortable going out to vote in
november
and that would be great it would be
great if trump wearing a mask
increases everybody's mass compliance
which makes more democrats feel
comfortable
going out and safely voting in november
if the death toll goes down
significantly that may actually be what
helps trump
the most and the mask wearing could be
part of it
but it's a long path right the mask
wearing you need eight to ten weeks to
flatten the case curve
it's about another 15 20 days to deal
with the deaths
and then we're at election day so i just
don't know that the timing is going to
work out
unemployment going down stock market
continuing to climb i don't think is
going to do very much for donald trump
in terms of the polls it really
fundamentally comes down to
can donald trump avoid another major
mistake like
the response to the george floyd protest
was a disaster trump's now more than 20
points underwater on racial relations
compared to joe biden disaster
trump's early coronavirus response
disaster you know carrying the mask
around now i think is too little too
late
the resulting economic damage and the
fact that
1200 bucks is what's gone out to some
people disaster
if trump can avoid another major mistake
if deaths do start to go down
if the economy does start to improve in
a real measurable way that will help
donald trump but ultimately he's
desperate he knows it
and it is now about lying about the
numbers to try to hide them
and and trying to suppress the vote
which is why we have to work really
really hard
to prevent that from happening we have
to overwhelm the vote by so much
that the voter suppression trump will
plan to do is planning to do
won't be enough to hand him a
re-election victory hey david people
often talk about
if x wins i'm moving to canada what
would it really take for you to leave
the united states
this is a good question i mean remember
so i was born in argentina moved to the
u.s when i was five
anytime i want to i could move back to
argentina
the economy is a disaster in argentina a
lot of the
it's not exactly a place i would love to
be from the standpoint of the virus
although things aren't great in the
united states
in massachusetts things are pretty good
um and massachusetts can continue to be
you know a good place to live in general
um theoretically
i could move to israel and
after a year i believe i would become
eligible for citizenship so
if the question is of the places i could
realistically go
and and move to permanently what would
it take i mean things would have to get
pretty
pretty bad here in the united states and
particularly in massachusetts things
have to get worse
we do have a country of 50 states and
the situat living in massachusetts
is very different than living in
mississippi from the standpoint of
health education
climate business regulation social
issues it's completely different
if things got really bad in
massachusetts or i believe that they
were going to
i would look at a sort of sabbatical of
sorts
not from work i would just work
elsewhere and depending on the
coronavirus situation
argentina could be a possibility and
israel could be a possibility right now
i don't see either of them as
places i would move to in the immediate
what would it take for me to permanently
abandon the united states
i don't know i mean you know my parents
live here um
my girlfriend's family is in the united
states
uh i have most of my relatives are in
argentina
some in france some in israel some in
you know different places
my social life is in the united states i
have a us-based business which i could
run from another country but it's
certainly easier being here it would
really take a lot and this is why
when we hear oh billionaires will
abandon the country if taxes go up
maybe a couple of them will but by and
large
people live where they live for reasons
and the longer they live there the more
attached they are
to it and it would really take a lot for
me to say i'm just leaving the united
states
permanently it doesn't seem something
that i would be likely to do now that
being
said i have said if things were to get
very bad in massachusetts
in the fall with the virus would i look
to see
can i without breaking any rules can i
go
somewhere that's doing well quarantine
for 14 days take a negative test and
sort of just do the show elsewhere for
four months or five months until things
settle down could it be uh you know some
picturesque
part of rural northern france or
something i mean that sounds amazing
that is a different story but in terms
of truly just abandoning the united
states
it's not likely and i think we have to
be really careful to
take too seriously any time someone says
if x wins if x loses i'm leaving the
country particularly by the way
when a lot of the people that say that
often say they would move to countries
that represent what it is they are
trying to avoid
you'll hear republicans say if trump
wins i'm leaving the country and going
to x y or z
uh a lot of those countries if trump
loses rather
or if obama wins we heard it i'm moving
to x country
most of those countries are more in the
direction of obama than what some of
these people want
really counter-intuitive and for the
most part these are empty threats that
we shouldn't pay too much attention to
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member at joinpacman.com
we will see you then or otherwise on
monday
you